Polycast is for
anybody who's really
into web components in Polymer.
If you're an absolute
beginner, you
haven't worked with
these things before, I'm
going to give you some getting
started material, show you how
to work with a few components.
If you're a more
advanced developer,
I actually have
some tips and tricks
and other cool
stuff that's coming
exclusive from
the Polymer teams.
So you get to hear about it
before pretty much anybody else
in the outside world.
We've got a little
bit of Hollywood magic
that we've incorporated
into the show
so that I can draw
on the screen,
I can point out the
particulars of the code,
and I can actually bring you
inside the text editor with me.
So it can feel more like we're
building a component together,
and not like you're just sitting
there watching some video.
Polycast comes out on the
Google Developers YouTube
channel every two weeks.
So you can subscribe
to that channel.
And that way, you will
never miss an episode,
which is pretty awesome.
You can also go find our
playlist on the channel.
You can bookmark
that, and you can
see the entire back catalog.
One thing I would say to
any developer watching
is that if you
really like the show,
leave me a comment
down there on YouTube.
I read all of the comments.
I try to respond to as
many as I possibly can.
And when you leave a
really good question,
we can highlight it
in future episodes.
Today on Polycast,
I'm going to show you
a very important trick.
So let's dive in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]